in other news the jury in galene
maxwell's sex abuse trial will continue
deliberating today maxwell as you know
is accused of recruiting and grooming
girls for jeffrey epstein's alleged sex
abuse ring she faces six counts linked
to sex trafficking and alleged sex acts
with a minor she has pleaded not guilty
to all charges now if convicted she
could be sent to prison for up to 70
years mola langis at the federal
courthouse in manhattan with more on
this story muller good morning to you
well good morning gail you might
remember that there was some speculation
that glenn maxwell might take the stand
but on friday she told the court that
there was no need for her to testify in
her own defense because the prosecution
had not proven their case beyond a
reasonable doubt of course that is what
the jury will ultimately decide over the
course of the trial jurors heard from
four accusers who testified that maxwell
recruited them into a world of sexual
abuse the youngest said that she was
recruited at 14 years old now in its
closing arguments yesterday the
prosecution insisted that maxwell was
the key to the entire operation the jury
was also reminded that one of the
victims testified that she was paid
hundreds of dollars to give epstein
sexual massages that allegation of
course is at the heart of the commercial
sex trafficking charge that maxwell
faces now the defense argued that
victims
have inconsistent memories at least the
ones who testified here and that they
were motivated by money having received
large settlements from epstein's victim
compensation fund now in closing
arguments the defense said that dating
epstein might have been the biggest
mistake of maxwell's life but that in
and of itself was not a crime so the
jury's decision really hinges on a
question
was
maxwell and epstein were they partners
in crime like the prosecution
alleges or is maxwell being made a
scapegoat
for epstein's alleged sex trafficking
operation that's what the jury
is deciding
guys
disturbing details indeed mueller thank
you